Let's determine the moment
of inertia of a big wheel.
Here we have a big wheel and
on the side it's attached here
at the center .
And there's a string going
around here, and on that string
is a little mass hanging.
And our disk here
has a radius R.
And we now want to in
a little experiment
what the moment of
inertia is of this disk.
And what we have
to do is we have
to drop this mass to
the ground, and we
need to measure
what height is here,
and we need to measure
how long it takes to drop.
So we need to measure t.
So how are we going
to go about that?
Well the moment of
inertia, that probably
has something to do with
the torque of this wheel.
So we have to start
doing a torque analysis.
So torque about the center of
mass equals moment of inertia
about the center of mass times
the angular acceleration.
And we need to recall
that the torque is
the product of the radius
times the perpendicular force,
so we're going to
have R here, and then
the force that's
acting on this wheel
here is actually this
tension force here.
So we are going to
have our RT here.
And now we need to look at
how things actually moving
with respect to
coordinate system.
So if I let this mass
drop, to the disk
it's going to spin clockwise.
So we're going to have
theta hat going this way.
And if theta hat
is going clockwise,
my k hat vector is going
to go into the board.
And if k hat is
going to go there,
and it's rotating clockwise,
the angular acceleration
is going to go in
the k hat direction.
And if that is the
case, then the torque
is going to follow suit.
So torque also goes
into the board.
And so that means
here we're going
to deal with k hat direction.
And we're going to
have Icm and then
alpha Z in the k hat direction.
OK, so we can solve this
I RT over alpha Z. OK,
well that's pretty good, but
we have two unknowns-- the T
and the alpha Z. And we can use
some other concepts to actually
get information on those.
The T, as you can guess
already, plays a role here
in this massless string, so
we can do a quick free body
diagram, an F equals ma analysis
to get to that tension force.
So we have a little mass, m,
here gravity is acting on it.
And we have this
tension force here.
And we're going
to put j hat down.
So we're going to get
mg minus t, equals ma.
It's only going to
go in y direction,
so we can just leave it here.
And we can solve this for t.
And then we have mg minus a.
OK, good, so we have that.
Now about the
angular acceleration.
And whenever there was a string
going around a disk then,
we of course, have a
constrained condition,
because the linear acceleration
of this little mass going down
is related to the radius of
the disk, times the angular
acceleration.
So we can solve this for alpha.
And then we have a over R.
So let's put that in here.
R, and then we have
mg minus a over a,
and then we get another R here.
And we can write that a little
bit more compact, mR squared g
over a minus 1.
Good, so now we have one last
hurdle, namely that a here.
That a we can't measure.
I said in the beginning, we
want to make an experiment.
Actually we need experiment,
because we can't otherwise
get to this a, so
what we need is
a relation that connects what we
can measure, which is the time.
It falls down the height here to
the acceleration of this block.
And of course, that comes from
one dimensional kinematics.
And we know that h equals 1/2 at
squared, so we can solve for a.
2h over t squared.
And now we can
stick that in here.
And we have mR squared, gt
squared over 2h minus 1.
And let's just write
this here again.
And that is our final solution.
So now we have only
measurable quantities here.
The t we can measure.
We just need a stopwatch.
And the h we can
measure, as well.
And this actually
already resembles,
if you know the
theoretical, this already
resembles the
theoretical solution,
which of course is for a disk.
1/2 mR squared, so that's
what one expects for a disk.
And you see that we're very
close, so this term here
is probably something
like 1.5, or should better
come out to be 1.5,
because if we subtract 1,
we get to that 1/2 here.
And you can use it to
in return-- in return,
you can also use it
to predict the time
it takes to fall down if
you know what the height is
or vice versa.